[Musica]
come parlare di energia rinnovabile
energie pulite senza dire cose che
vengono dette più o meno tutti i giorni
sui media
bella domanda per rispondere alla quale
ho pensato di raccontarvi le mie
rinnovabili
quindi il mio percorso perché ciò
dedicato la vita quindi partiamo da sarà
chi è sara sara è un'appassionata di
evoluzione
io amo il cambiamento in tutte le sue
forme
considerate che delle quattro stagioni
la mia preferita il cambiamento fra una
e l'altra quindi 15 anni fa quando mi
sono unito al settore del del green
delle energie pulite quello era il
maggior cambiamento in atto
nell'industria in quel momento non lo
faceva ancora quasi nessuno eravamo dei
pionieri però avevamo già immaginato
delle cose
avevamo immaginato delle cose che si
sono poi realizzate esempio avevamo
immaginato che le rinnovabili avrebbero
fatto diminuire il prezzo dell'energia
questo perché nelle con le rinnovabili
noi non paghiamo il prezzo del
combustibile ragionamento è semplice se
volete non dovendo pagare il prezzo del
combustibile monte né il prezzo
dell'energia finale questa componente
non c'è quindi è più basso il prezzo
effettivamente in 15 anni il prezzo
dell'energia elettrica è scesa di circa
il 30 per cento in italia poi avevamo
immaginato che avremmo cambiato
completamente il modello energetico da
un modello centralizzato con la centrale
termoelettrica tradizionale lontana
lontana dagli occhi lontano dal cuore la
vedevano in pochi
l'energia arrivava a casa un po come se
fosse lì dovuta ad un deus ex machina e
nessuno sapeva fondamentalmente nulla
quando con l'introduzione delle
rinnovabili la filiera si è cominciato
ad accorciare quindi siamo andati verso
un modello di energia distribuito e
decentralizzato quindi
diano a noi utenti finali questa
produzione si è cominciato ad avvicinare
fino ad arrivare davanti ai nostri occhi
addirittura sulle nostre teste coni con
il solare e questo ha fatto sì che noi
cominciassimo a chiederci ma adesso sto
producendo sto consumando quanto quanto
pago sto inquinando e questo ha fatto sì
che ci responsabilizza assimo si è
creata una responsabilizzazione che sta
procedendo e aumenterà sempre di più nel
utente finale
questo è il rito con una parola molto
bella inglese che il prossimo per il
produttore e il consumatore si uniscono
diventano un tutt'uno attendere terzo
punto più intuitivo immaginavamo i tempi
che avremmo migliorato la qualità
dell'aria uno dei miei grandi sogni
avere l'aria di alta montagna in città
un giorno se arriveremo però è è
dimostrato ad oggi le brevi un articolo
di un paio di anni fa uscito sul network
che dimostrava come effettivamente nei
paesi più sviluppati in cui c'erano
state politiche volte a favorire le
energie rinnovabili e l'efficienza
energetica come effettivamente negli
ultimi dieci anni si fossero ridotte le
emissioni di circa il 2 per cento l'anno
quindi cose molto belle che hanno dato
vita a qualcosa di grandioso che i green
minuti il green new deal europeo è
testualmente la nuova strategia di
crescita europea
questo che vuol dire che non è una cosa
carina non è un'appendice non è un di
cui di qualcosa no il green new deal
europeo e mondiale perché come cia in
europa facendo il resto del mondo è la
base fondante della nostra economia del
nostro sviluppo e della nostra società
da oggi fino al 2050
l'obiettivo numerico del green new deal
è
il primo il primario obiettivo è quello
di arrivare al 2050 venere emissioni
nette pari a zero voi considerate che
nel fino agli anni 2000 noi avevamo
rinnovabili pressoché nulle
ad oggi siamo con la media europea di
consumi rinnovabili su consumi finali
dell'energia di circa il 20 per cento
fra 30 anni praticamente dovremo essere
al 100 per cento quindi siamo ben
lontani dalla fine e abbiamo ancora
molto molto da fare quindi cose
bellissime e molto concrete stupende che
avevamo immaginato in qualche forma
cos'è che non avevamo immaginato
noi non avevamo immaginato che le
rinnovabili e l'energia pulita e
l'efficienza energetica avrebbero
cambiato il nostro modo di pensare noi
non immaginavamo che avrebbero cambiato
la nostra società nei suoi valori nella
scala di valori è successo qualcosa di
stupefacente di incredibilmente grande
che veramente va oltre tutte quelle che
potevano essere le idee l'immaginazione
di chiunque di noi per capire in che
forma dobbiamo un pochino allargare la
visuale
noi abbiamo una tecnologia che un trend
tecnologico che è quello dell'energia
pulita che è un filone partito da
qualche anno che ormai è diciamo struzzo
la bocca di tutti c'è tanto da fare ma è
avviato altri due trend e importanti che
sono partite negli ultimi anni che sono
in crescita sono uno anzi due perché
primo è l'energia pulita la
digitalizzazione la digitalizzazione e
l'informatizzazione delle cose la
vediamo questa nella nostra vita di
tutti i giorni il coin ha ci ha aiutato
su questo ad avere un boost pazzesco
nelle nostre vite di tutti i giorni e ha
cambiato in modo sostanziale fra le
altre cose il modo in cui noi
interagiamo l'uno con l'altro terzo
trend
l'intelligenza artificiale qui si è
fatto tanto c'è ancora moltissimo da
fare probabilmente tra le tre e le altre
fra i tre il trend che ha un maggior
potenziale ancora di crescita
l'intelligenza artificiale cosa permesso
tra le altre cose permesso di cambiare
il modo in cui lavoriamo
la robotizzazione dell'industria e la lo
sviluppo delle macchine ha fatto sì che
il modo in cui noi lavoriamo sia
cambiato radicalmente ogni 3 trend come
si uniscono e che effetto hanno dal mio
punto di vista ha due effetti
eccezionali 1 l'economia sostenibile
noi siamo passati dall economia green
verde all'economia sostenibile non è
banale non è la stessa cosa
economia sostenibile nasce da dal
cambiamento che dentro di noi è partito
qualche anno fa con con il green in cui
noi per la prima volta abbiamo guardato
al bene di qualcuno o di qualcos'altro
per crescere per evolvere nello sviluppo
tecnologico e nello sviluppo
dell'umanità noi abbiamo pensato al bene
di qualcun altro e non è banale neanche
questo da lì oggi si sono sviluppate le
cosiddette metri che human centric uomo
centri che fino a pochi anni fa le
grandi aziende si basavano le proprie
valutazioni valutazione delle altre
aziende di se stesse su metriche
puramente finanziarie oggi ci sono le
metriche human centric e non è un
concetto naif e non è un concetto
teorico non è un concetto vago è un
concetto concreto ci sono dati che
dimostrano che le aziende che hanno un
approccio un approccio uomo centrico
valgono di più economicamente hanno un
valore in borsa che cresce
hanno più valore di benessere è uguale a
soldi è un cambiamento epocale
cos'altro è cambiato quindi economia
sostenibile 2 economia decentralizzata
questa come abbiamo detto prima allora
le energie rinnovabili
mi permettono di avere l'energia dove
voglio quindi io posso produrre dove
voglio
non ho più un problema della centrale
termoelettrica la digitalizzazione
permette alle persone di lavorare da
dove vogliono quindi io posso produrre
dove voglio
l'intelligenza artificiale mi permette
di mettere i macchinari dove voglio
perché si è spostato il concept
dell'industria si è spostato da un
concetto ad intensità di manodopera ad
un concetto ad intensità di capitale
quindi non c'è più c'è sempre di meno e
ci sarà sempre di meno
la competizione dei paesi con la
manovalanza a costo più basso quindi
posso produrre dove voglio
l'economia può arrivare ovunque filiere
del valore possono crearsi ovunque
non c'è più bisogno di andare in alcuni
paesi piuttosto che in altri si può
creare una filiera industriale
sviluppata senza veramente che manchi
nulla che abbia nulla da invidiare a
catania a foggia a roma l'aquila ancora
ovunque e quindi questi due concetti
come hanno cambiato noi c'è solo 8
quindi con gli inglesi quindi noi che ci
cambia due messaggi che vi vorrei
lasciare uno vogliatevi bene
l'economia sostenibile ci insegna che ci
dobbiamo voler bene noi dobbiamo voler
bene a noi e agli altri
dobbiamo partire da noi il bene
dell'individuo è la base fondante per la
nuova economia per il nuovo mondo
se volete andare a vedere una mostra
andateci oggi se dovete andare a correre
andateci oggi non domani parte dalle
piccole cose ma voler bene a se stessi
poi alla propria famiglia alla propria
comunità dell'ambiente e la
base fondante per la nuova economia se
avete un azienda siete imprenditori e
gestiti un'azienda pensate al bene dei
vostri dipendenti perché come abbiamo
detto prima il bene è denaro vi porta
valore in termini umani in termini anche
economici
se avete una famiglia gestita una
famiglia
vogliate bene a voi stessi vogliate bene
alla famiglia e pensate alle piccole
cose come posso fare per migliorare
l'ambiente che affiancando attorno a me
non ci possiamo affidare solo alla
differenziata pensate come ridurre in
ingresso quello che utilizzate
e come ridurlo in uscita e poi secondo
messaggio l'economia decentralizzata è
un potenziale pazzesco per tutti è a mio
avviso per paesi come l'italia in un
modo ancor maggiore
oggi abbiamo una disponibilità di
liquidità enorme ci sono i fondi europei
ci sono i fondi dei fondi d'investimento
ci sono i fondi delle banche e sono
tanti molto più che nel periodo che ci
ha preceduto ci sono le tecnologie
quindi se avete un'idea un'idea valida
che porti benessere alle persone che
porti benessere al mondo che porti
benessere alla vostra comunità portatela
avanti perché questo è il momento per
portarla avanti e per fare veramente
grandi cose
[Applauso]
[Musica]